hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this is going to be a
sponsor free somewhat unusual episode
and I implore you to please listen to
the whole thing I have been in
quarantine / self-isolation with my
girlfriend and Molly my pop for about
four weeks now and have been tracking
all of this very very closely since the
beginning I've also been in close
contact with people working in emergency
rooms ICU etc in New York as well as
prior to that Italy and other places so
I've had an ear to the ground for some
time
I expect next week is currently Friday
March 20th to be an exceptionally
difficult week for many people in many
cities New York City chief among them
and if you are lucky enough to be
listening to this podcast and healthy
you likely oh something to a health care
worker if it weren't for health care
workers I would be dead as one example
if not for health care workers my dad
would have died of a heart attack at
least three uncle's at least two aunts
just off the top of my head would be
dead or it not for health care workers
and much like a seatbelt or an airbag
these are things in this case people who
are of incredible importance and you
don't really notice them until you need
them so I would encourage you to think
of health care workers alongside people
working on vaccine development and drug
development as the walls of this city
these are the people who are most
important to protect right now if we
want to recover quickly from the current
SARS Cove to Cove it 19 pandemic threat
if you want just in enlightened
self-interest you want the markets to
rebound you want your investments to
rebound you want life to go back to
normal the first thing I would draw your
attention to is ensuring that healthcare
workers that's what we're going to focus
on this episode have what they need to
fight extremely effectively that is
critically important because as soon as
we have shortages of
we have many many more compounding
problems so this episode is going to
bounce around a bit and I'm going to
highlight things that can be done and
I'm also going to highlight companies I
hope continue to do work and some that
might be good options for people to
explore as well as a number of resources
and I'm going to read first just from
some notes that I've taken over the last
few weeks of speaking with very very
very credible physicians on the front
lines who are not only doing the work
themselves with patients as clinicians
but who are also in management positions
so in no particular order here we go
doctors nurses pas techs doing x-rays
technicians that is cleaning staff these
are all people who are making incredible
sacrifices for you anyone listening to
this every day and if you are one of
these healthcare workers suffice to say
I want to give you my sincerest thanks
you are going to make the difference
here you are one of the most important
elements in this entire puzzle so thank
you for doing what you do right now
physicians feel very let down by the
federal government they have a lack of
PPE personal protective equipment and so
on they did sign up many of them to risk
their lives and help others but they do
need support so here are a few of the
things that have come up repeatedly as
very important and very immediate and by
immediate I mean not to act like
Nostradamus but I've very accurately
predicted a lot of what would happen
over the last four weeks and next week I
anticipate to be a very difficult week
in New York City and these people need
help right now not next Tuesday not next
Thursday but ASAP immediately the first
is temporary housing temporary housing
for health care workers slash providers
so they can rest instead of commuted for
instance and also not go home and risk
infecting elderly parents
and I am going to call a few people out
here for thanks and also hopefully to
jump into the fray to help the first is
Airbnb so at Airbnb
on Twitter I would like to thank for
already having deployed experiments in
Italy helping with temporary housing so
Airbnb and I also want to say just in
general private enterprises really
stepping up many to try to help where
the government is failing
so Airbnb is already doing experiments
and I really hope they continue to run
experiments in the u.s. nowhere is that
more urgent than in New York City at the
moment next I'd like to bring up Hilton
Hotels at Hilton Hotels certainly not
the only hotel chain or Hospitality
Group that could help in these
circumstances for instance you have and
I'm going to get the name pronunciation
wrong here but Gary Neville famous
soccer player and Chelsea Chairman Roman
Abramovich in the UK are making their
hotels available for health care workers
right now this is extremely valuable
so Hilton is having a tough time as our
many in hospitality and I have listened
to quite a bit from Bill Ackman at Bill
Ackman who is deeply involved with
Hilton and I think that there is
tremendous opportunity right now to not
only do a lot of good but also set
Hilton and fill-in-the-blank if you are
involved in another hotel or a
hospitality group up for success later
and I will commit right now to
highlighting and promoting anyone who
steps up meaning larger companies who
step up and even smaller if I find you
on Twitter and I see you but larger
companies especially I will I will
promote and put my machine behind you if
you step up now for New York City and
other cities who need help all right so
that's air B&B clap clap please expand
what you're doing keep doing what you're
doing and at Hilton Hotels and by
association since I don't know anyone
else to get directly to
Hylton that is Bill Ackman who I think
has thought very clearly about a lot
related to this pandemic next up is food
food we need to keep people not just
rested but also fed and food can be very
difficult for people on grilling shifts
in the ER what I don't want and I had to
think very carefully about the call to
action here is for people to suddenly
show up at ers with hundreds of boxes of
pizza I think that will create just as
one example more problems more confusion
more contagion than any thing it would
solve but there are a few options here
so the first is there are a number of
companies for instance you have sweet
greens who is delivering meals to health
care workers at sweet green I believe it
is singular and then you have uber eats
I think ubereats is probably the
operator who has the most leverage here
to do the most good and uber eats at
ubereats has already said and this was a
pinned tweet from March 16th we're
committing 300,000 plus meals to
healthcare workers and first responders
so that is a huge deal and if I try to
find the instructions for how to take
advantage of that as a health care
worker I can't find it so at uber II
it's please make it clearer on your
Twitter account and elsewhere how people
can actually take advantage of this all
I see is on the linked blog post
interested officials and organizations
can reach us at and then the email which
is social - impact - support at uber
calm again that social - impact -
support at uber calm but this is very
cumbersome it is not expedient the
instructions need to be very clear or
the plans need to be very clear and the
need is immediate this isn't something
that can be conveniently rolled out over
12 months if you really want to help now
is the time to help so I appreciate you
making the commitment and please make
the instructions and announcements much
much clearer and for people who are
listening or asking how can I personally
help I'm going to be creating a
Ritt email list of people who are
interested in different types of helping
and I will let you know right now things
are very messy and there are many ways
to become confused and waste resources I
will give you one option in a few
minutes but suffice to say go to tim dot
blog forward slash fight KO vyd that's
Tim DUP log forward slash fight KO vid
and add your name and email and I will
do my best to share with you vetted
options for helping all right now I said
I was going to mention something where
you might be able to help and that is
coming up right now so announcement
today that came out this is from Ryan
Peterson PTR Sen at types fast on
Twitter he is the CEO of flex port and
here's the announcement Paul Graham at
Paul G and then subtext for those who
don't know of Y Combinator fam just
donated 1 million dollars to flex port
org that gift will pay for almost all of
the protective gear required by the
entire city of San Francisco's frontline
health care workers will likely
distribute the equipment to hospitals
and other locations all right
flex port flex Borg is Global Logistics
and sustainability and as we scroll down
I'm looking at Paul's response to that
and I encourage everyone to follow Paul
Graham on Twitter here's what he says
potential donors I've known Ryan for
many years and know how extraordinarily
effective he is so if the hospitals in
your city lack protective equipment ask
Ryan and he'll go get it for you who was
Paul Graham if you don't know he was
involved in helping get companies like
Dropbox air B&B credit etc off the
ground that's the very simplified
version but take that seriously so do
take a look if you're interested in
supporting personal protective equipment
one option maybe flex port org and you
can take a look at that as well as flex
port comm forward slash donate
next up we've covered temporary housing
we've covered food we've covered the
personal protective equipment for now at
home testing which would minimize the
number of people showing up at clinics
unannounced asking for testing and
causing further chaos I will keep
everyone posted on findings that I come
across which are promising related to ad
home testing if you go again teamed up
log forward so I should fight kovat I
will also put that on social and I'll
put it on Twitter my account is T Ferris
so Twitter comm /t fer Riss the next few
things I'm going to touch upon are what
Amazon might be able to do that would
allow citizen philanthropists that is
individuals and not large companies to
help and I will also talk about
ventilators and this is new specifically
for healthcare workers to increase the
capacity of ventilators and actually
I'll speak to that first a lot of talk
right now is about manufacturing
ventilators because cities are likely
not certain but very likely to face in
the United States and elsewhere
shortages of ventilators we saw this in
Italy and elsewhere were physicians had
to make the decision of who would live
and who would die and calculating the
number of likely healthy years that
someone might have and choosing
accordingly things of that type it would
be best if our physicians don't have to
make those choices this is not a point
zero zero one percent likelihood this is
a I'm not going to say probable but very
possible problem that we will experience
in the United States and while we are
manufacturing ventilators there are
techniques for modifying ventilators so
that you can use a single ventilator not
on one person but two or four and I've
put up a blog post describing this this
is all provided to me and vetted by
people in the medical community at
teamed up blog forward slash ventilator
so if you got teamed up blog forward
slash ventilator
that will show you and also talks about
some of the complexities how to modify
existing ventilators without new
shipments of ventilators so that you can
increase capacity there are also some
other options that I outlined in that
blog post so for that if you are in the
hospital systems healthcare communities
some of you will already be familiar
with some of these options but many of
you will not please go to Tim Doug
forward slash ventilator and you will
find that information alright so we've
covered ten pausing we've covered food
we've covered the personal protective
equipment ventilators at-home testing I
said I'll keep people apprised of via
email and also on social and really last
because I don't have a solution for
child care that is another one that
health care workers really need help
with I don't have a solution or a
proposed solution right now for that
Amazon can do something interesting here
and I suspect they already are on some
level but to really make it publicly
known and available so that people can
help Amazon can create gift cards
vouchers that are restricted to for
instance protective equipment and my
understanding could be incorrect but
that this would not then be taxable to
the recipients as long as these are
things that are absolutely needed and
this also helps to minimize the
likelihood of fraud because one of the
issues related to trying to help
is that fraudsters and cons and
charlatans will pop up and try to take
advantage of these opportunities so
Amazon can mitigate against that by
creating gift cards and vouchers that
are restricted to protective equipment
so that you could for instance go in buy
these cards and then provide them to
your local hospital or local ER or
anywhere you grew up or wherever you
would like to help there's probably a
more elegant solution to distributing
that widely but Amazon is in a fantastic
position to do a lot of good and I'm
sure they're already doing a lot
amazon of course on twitter so that's a
lot in one episode I know this is more
of a PSA and a call-to-action than
anything else but really we're going to
get through this we will get through
this and right now if you are able it is
the time to be a generous life guard not
a selfish drowning person there are
people who are drowning there are people
who really need assistance financially
and if you have trouble paying for food
paying bills other needs etc please go
to find help org and you can find free
and reduced cost services for many
things in every city in the United
States but some of us are in positions
to help more of us are in positions to
help then might realize that is the case
and as one of the doctors in New York
City told me every small Act goes a long
way especially given how much fear there
is among the staff medical staff that is
there being maxed out and even just a
thank you when you see them on the
street or if you see them on the street
if you want to say something to them on
social media can be incredibly
meaningful where millions of people now
get to work from home for safety these
incredible people do not have that
option and many of them take very
seriously the oaths they've made to
protect and serve us and in exchange or
at the very least we need these people
properly fed rested and able to continue
fighting we all depend on them so last
but not least say your thanks do it on
social media say it to anyone you know
who is involved on the front lines
they're going to be separated from their
families in some cases for extended
periods of time these are our first
responders in front line of defense and
I'm taking it very very seriously
because we all depend on them we have
all depended on them and sometimes we
just don't realize it but that is always
true and one option this may not be the
best option but in showing your
solidarity you could
choose for instance the color green and
just create a boundary or some type of
highlight in your social profile that
says I support medical right so hashtag
support medical support medical support
medical hashtag support medical and the
color green right that's one thing that
you can do even if you don't have any
money any contacts and the ability to
think about flex port who reads any of
these things that I'm talking about what
else can you do to help you can also
take some of these links that I am
sharing including Tim top log forward
slash a ventilator for modifying and
increasing capacity of enta laters or
tinned up log forward slash fight Co vid
where I will eventually be sharing
different targeted vetted options for
people who want to help and I would say
that is probably enough for this episode
so thank you so much for listening I
appreciate you all I am really trying to
put in the good fight
to help as much as possible I realize
how fortunate I am to be safe to have
food and I take that as a moral
obligation to do what I can to fight for
people who are fighting for us thanks so
much for listening
you